la nouvelle souche de grippe aviaire de
type H5 N1 et plus mortel que jamais et
elle gagne du terrain partout dans le
monde à une vitesse inédite seulement en
France la facture associée aux pertes
dans le secteur de la volaille dépasse
un milliard d'euros depuis un an et on
avait 60 % de mortalité sur des petits
canetons comme on voit là et il faut le
voir quoi c'est assez catastrophique
aujourd'hui au moins 80 pays sont
touchés et 200 millions d'oiseaux
sauvages ou domestiques ont été infectés
aux États-Unis on a déjà abattu 60
millions de poulet et le prix des œufs a
presque doublé il n'y a pas que les
éleveurs de volailles qui sont menacés
énormément d'espèces d'oiseaux mais
également des mammifères depuis un mois
près de 600 carcasses de même fait marin
décédé de la grippe aviaire ont été
découverts sur les plages de Lima au
Pérou on rapporte également des cas de
vision de furet et de renard mort
probablement après avoir mangé des
carcasses d'oiseaux infectés la
transmission du virus de la grippe
aviaire chez l'humain est également
possible mais c'est encore une menace
hypothétique selon l'OMS pour le moment
il faut dire que les cas rapportés
d'infection au H5 N1 chez l'humain sont
rares à peine 868 cas depuis 20 ans même
si le taux de mortalité lui est
impressionnant
53%. pour ralentir la pandémie et
permettre de l'industrie de souffler un
peu on s'engènes possible vaccination
mais c'est une solution complexe et très
coûteuse la vaccination c'est pas viable
à court terme c'est pas ça prendrait un
vaccin qui soit compatible avec les
souches sauvages qu'on a là depuis le
printemps dernier quelques fermes
d'élevage canadiennes et québécoises ont
été touchés par la grippe aviaire mais
pour l'instant les dégâts sont limités
ici normand Grondin Radio-Canada
Montréal